so I'm here at Worlds comic-con with
Kings Bastian himself mark at the market
lovely to meet you and you and you yes
great here that was quite a crowd here
today
really there's queues everywhere Arthur
yep yeah it was I was here last year and
there were a lot of people last year but
I think this year it's the since we
twice the number of people but it's
great you know it's fantastic you meet a
lot of really really interesting folk I
mark tell me how you found it playing
Robert Baratheon obviously the king of
the Seven Kingdoms
yeah well he's he's the king but he's
he's not happy and you know he's he's a
very troubled soul because he you know
he took over he took over leadership in
a kind of supposed like a a coup if you
like they knew that to get rid of the
the Mad King Aerys because he was he was
just a crazy guy killing his own people
lunatic dictator but then in the void
that's left who's gonna who's gonna take
the reigns and Robert decides to sort of
foolishly but it's not the bed of roses
that he thought it was going to be and
he's gonna deal with I'll see little you
know domestic issues
it was just not what I eat whoa check it
out what he got into the job pot in the
first place oh he's a troubled soul and
he's stuck in a loveless marriage with
with one of his you know his biggest
enemies basically and he realizes almost
too late that he surrounded himself by
by Lannisters not a great position to be
in really you have to say who you think
would come out on top at the end of the
day in game as far as you do think would
be to get me the House Stark House
Lannister House Targaryen yeah it's a
tricky one I think I think ultimately
the Starks should triumph but that
remains to be seen I think you know the
Starks and obviously Jay include Jon
Snow in there but they are you know
they're they're the they're the best of
the of the people actually Tyrion will
probably triumph imagine he seems to
land on his feet the game he does like
playing the game and he's very good at
it yeah what qualities do you think you
needed maybe King Robert was lacking to
survive in Game of Thrones that's a
tough question I think you have to be
ruthless and I think you you have to be
aware of everything that's going on
around you
for a kickoff I personally would change
the change the members of my small
Council and make sure I'm getting advice
from the right kind of person that
everybody's got their own self interests
at heart so it's tricky - yes it's a
tricky one to gauge but ya know I think
yeah I think I'd get my advisors in
order I think how do you think we
deferred if you were actually in Roberts
world because it took our world to live
it isn't it yeah it's it's brutal and
there's no you know there's very little
mercy shown I'd only had last long to be
honest but but it's ya know it's it's
fantastic to just just step into that
world momentarily and pretend to be a
part of it and not have to actually live
through any of that ya know it's it's
tough it's tough but but you know then
that's why the characters become what
they become and you know they all change
in different ways but but it is a tough
world and you have to they have to find
a way to survive and to overcome the
odds
it may just makes it fascinating that's
there you know that's the great thing
about it is a you know it's a brilliant
tale and it you never know where it's
going to take you that's it that's one
of the reasons why we live a always
getting the rug filled anything it's
aren't we and when you got the chop it
was death by bra wasn't it what did he
feel about that yeah I was hoping that
you'd get to see the death but
unfortunately like in the book it's all
just sort of reported but there you know
I think my favorite death was Viserys
with the gold that's got to be high on
the list of top screen deaths of all
time so yeah I mean being being killed
by a pig pales into insignificance
compared with that you delight to have
gone without gold on your head you know
it was sort of a ironically pathetic way
to die really everyone's gonna eat it no
no that I've got have a feast
Mary yeah no I hope that happens when I
go yeah a big party let's see what's it
like working with them you work with the
number of members of car sitting across
talena hideous er see you calls because
all the Lannister the Lannisters in
there you got Joffrey you've got Peter
Dinklage you've got Ned Stark of course
you shown being you watch before what's
it like working with all those guys it's
brilliant I mean it was it was it was
great working with Sean again we would
we were at drama school at the same time
and we did
red riding together for channel 4 so you
know we said we've got we have our own
sort of personal history and it's nice
to be able to bring that to the you know
to the floor when you you know you
playing friends that have known each
other for years and years so actually
knowing each other for a long time helps
you you know I mean it means you can
just get on and you know and be those
those characters so no terrific and Lina
is just a joy a joy to work with a lot
of laughs even though she's playing such
a [ __ ] character she's terrific and
you know of course Jack Jack Gleeson who
plays Joffrey isn't
it's an absolute sweetheart in real life
that's the you know I mean it's ease
play it's such a brilliant actor to play
you know it's such a hideous character I
think he's a genius you know he played
it really really well so it's just I had
such a good time working on it it was it
was a shame that I had to die that's the
way it goes
maybe you could come back you know is
the world of also mystery magic isn't it
it is but I think if they were gonna
bring Robert back for any useful purpose
that bring him back in his younger form
when he was fitting you know brutal and
a warrior rather than an old drunk what
use you'd be to anybody how important
would it be than reading those own
George are lost in books because
obviously all that's in there isn't it
all the night story it was really useful
for me because it gives you you know
that this in the scripts he's you know
he's grumpy and shouty and rude and
which is fine but the great thing about
the book says you realize exactly why he
is the way he is and the decisions the
poor decisions that he's made
[Music]
you know part of that and you know his
entire his entire history is there for
you to do absorb and it was great to be
able to do that to heaven you know that
that was a resource normally you'd have
to make up your own characters backstory
but with it all being there it's if you
had to be any other character you could
choose any other character part from
Robert obviously we loved you isn't it
when you enjoyed it
who would you like to play obviously if
I was if I was the correct height I
would tyrion would really isn't cuz
Tyrians just a cork in character he gets
he gets the lion's share of the best
lines and he's such a
he's a wise survivor I think that's I
loved the fact that he you know he gives
he gives snow advice about you know
realizing what you are and using using
that as a
as a defense you know the fact that the
fact that he's a dwarf says I know I'm a
dwarf
everybody else knows I'm a dwarf they're
not that's not they're not going to get
to me through that that's are you aware
that as Armour and it's you know it is
philosophy is it's interested intriguing
and it's and it's true I think you know
you can you can either let people and
let people put you down or you you know
you put your defenses up and in there
and it was water off a duck's back
that's that's where he that's why I
think he's such a brilliant character
never loves mark at the inn robert
baratheon as well we're sad to see you
go in that first season yeah it was but
you know I knew it was you know it was a
short-lived character but I really
enjoyed playing it and you know it's a
sort of privilege to be you know to be a
part of something that's of such high
quality and and creates a world unlike
anything I've ever seen what would you
like to say to the fans out there who
are watching this video fans a game of
Thrones I would like to say
ours is the fury Game of Thrones rules
you